hallo leute wie sieht eure mal waren und
wir kommen zu einem neuen video und
heute hätten wir ja hätte der welt okay
die jagd es viel zu tun ist damit nicht
kennen sowie macht immer sehr lustige
videos und verein macht er ganz oft mit
seiner schwester annie irgendwelche
dinge die meistens ein fail sind und
deswegen habt ihr mir auch sehr oft
gesagt hätte doch mal ein video von
doris ahnen und diese juni konnte diese
gebacken haben ist wirklich die
hässlichste torte der welt das ist ein
fall für stärken
kommen wir zu den zutaten wir brauchen
[Musik]
eine packung pulver lebensmittelfarbe
hamburger vegetarisches fertig macht ab
ohne die butter sehr nett und zuletzt
märz bevor aber natürlich brauchen wir
eine saubere arbeitsfläche doch ja ganz
wichtig zu erwähnen diese torte hat drei
torten als schwierigkeitsstufe dass das
schwierigste was geht so ich stehe am
anfang fest dass in die ohren und das
voran
aus dem weissen rolf von doch ein tag
sind vor ort hergestellt werden soll
das ist schon eine schüssel ich habe das
natürlich gemacht für die ohren das horn
braucht ihr erstmal einen weißen rolf an
den puderzucker und solche kleinen
holzspieße die könnt euch die
arbeitsfläche mit puderzucker
bestreichen das hilft ein bisschen
beides zu klebrig wird die können jetzt
das weiße rolle von don zurechtschneiden
den streifen oder einfach teile
wegschneiden und dann müsst ihr das so
kneten und zusammenrollen dass es halt
einhorn ergibt ich glaube man sollte
einfach selber ein bisschen ausprobieren
was ein pass wie man es am ende haben
wir dieses horn und man kann es dann an
dieses an diesen holzspielzeug machen
und ja dann habt ihr so einhorn und die
ohren formt ihr euch auch einfach aus
dem weißen rössl und das müsst ihr dann
zur seite legen und trocknen lassen und
wenn wir alles richtig gemacht habe dann
habt ihr am ende so ein weißes horn und
das können jetzt zur seite legen
wir machen mit dem kuchen weiter als das
gestern gemacht hat ist ja noch so viel
von dort übrig geblieben deshalb habe
ich mich noch an split probiert das sind
halt so kleine den kompletter mit denen
man die dort auch noch verziehen kann
und dann habe ich entschieden dass ich
komplett all hingehen möchte und habe
sogar rosen gebastelt das habe ich nicht
mehr aufgenommen weil das einfach
irgendwann entstanden ist dass ich
angefangen
einen anderen zu machen
ich habe echt lange versucht das rezept
zu finden damit ich das auch mal lesen
kann was er da eigentlich versucht zu
tun denn seine art die zutaten
miteinander zu verrühren er hat ja mixa
wies er könnte es richtig machen
er tut's aber nicht ist ja auch nicht
schlimm meint er kann viele der viele
andere talente aber das kann halt nicht
so gut da seine motive heute wirklich
lange dauert und ich nicht sallys welt
bin und hier keine 100 leute stehen die
mir beim wachsen helfen können habe ich
schon gestern den teig den kuchen
vorbereitet und jetzt könnt ihr sehen
wie ich das gemacht habe haben wir
gerade schon eingeschlagen wir haben
nicht mitbekommen dass die kamera nicht
mehr aufgenommen hatte
die bruttoerträge und jetzt mal zucker 1
auf die plätze fertig los
die eimasse beifügen ok
[Applaus]
besser als kurze wird es nicht außerdem
glaube ich mir jetzt kurse und
schokoladen wurde und vision masse 77
geld nicht selbst
und hier sind sie ich habe zweimal die
grünen gemacht weil bei einem ersten mal
die so schmal rauskam und daraus kannst
du ja keine motiv torte machen und dann
habe ich noch mal gemacht und die sind
jetzt auch ein bisschen größer geworden
und haben wir genug teig aus aufeinander
zu stapeln und eine tolle tore zu machen
kommen wir aber zur verfüllung natürlich
erst mal wieder unsere zeit erklärt
lassen sich nicht mal coolen dafür
überlegen mangold dann brauchen wir
natürlich wieder unseren treuen
wirksamen mangold und das muss ja
so siehts aufgeschlagene butter
außenbild tatsächlich weist jetzt kommt
die mascarpone in den topf was kaputt
und butter miteinander verrühren
in ihm werden wir müssen die mixen
maschine
du kannst es überall festmachen warum
sollte man sie besser da kommen jetzt
hingehen stimmung machen wissen worüber
sie mit david bowie liter wasser hat
eine schüssel und wenn man auch in
unserer muss jetzt die hände masse
[Musik]
happens und jetzt verlieren wir das
anders aus mit einem messer schneiden
die jetzt unsere böden
wir haben unseren ersten und das machen
wir jetzt mit allen höhen und wir
schneiden sie zu recht wenig einfach die
seiten hier
fast 38 uhr so wir müssen jetzt erst mal
aus beförderung ja sie ist das ist genau
der mann den du abschneiden muss fürs
tanzen kannst
damit es mir gefertigt ist bestimmt
nicht mal normal war
wir kommen zum finalen wichtige schmidt
ja eigentlich gar nicht der finale
schritt ist und schon mal keinen schnitt
bei diesen schritt jetzt unsere kurse
hin der acker passte und schmieren heißt
dazwischen sie echt nicht so geil aus
aber erfüllt ihren zweck würde ich mal
sagen
[Musik]
kann man die überhaupt essen wenn wir so
hoch ist stehen ist der ganze rest mein
gott wie gut aus so jetzt noch keine
gemacht und ich mache jetzt auch nicht
wirklich aber wir werden einmal den
kunden von außen mit eine komplette
bestreichen und ich habe einmal ein horn
zauber zitronengeschmack also in der
richtigen farbe schon und übermorgen wir
den kuchen oder so und die werden jetzt
flüssig machen kann da jetzt auch rein
hier haben wir unsere beiden glasur wie
möglich jetzt schon zusammen soll dazu
kommt jetzt dass man sie jetzt so
verstreichen ganz schöner natur gotha
mit dem mixer schauen können sich auch
nicht mehr berufen trixi scheiße
sie ist eine sehr flüssige buttercreme
die hälfte mit grüner und blauer
lebensmittel vereint werden bis das
gewünschte mitteilung heißt ist welche
meinung die mit grün braucht man ein
bisschen laut aber auch wir verglühen
und ganz wenig eben noch ein bisschen
brauchen sie sich verhält aber es sieht
so aus also ob ich mich über die tonne
mit lustig machen aber das ist wirklich
anstrengend
[Musik]
und was passiert ist damit klar es muss
wieder in den kühlschrank denn wir sind
noch lange nicht fertig
die ein motor
jetzt kommt die show klausur jetzt so
richtig dickflüssigen gehören dünnste
guck mal das ist darunter fließt die
teilweise aus den eu plan aber jetzt
kann und so wie geht's weiter auch die
korea mit den rosen
[Musik]
die ganze harte arbeit entscheiden sich
aus jetzt habe ich ja noch diese blätter
die hier so dekorativ hier wirklich
stoppen kann es ist noch eine harte
arbeit aber wenn das endergebnis ist so
geil
juli versuchen wie glaube ich auch ich
werde das auch die lücken oben bisschen
buttercreme füllen damit das einfach
voller aussieht
[Musik]
ganz sicher noch spät eingekauft augen
augen augen gesehen habe ist ein
bisschen zeit vergangen ist
fahrradfahren ob was zu mittag gegessen
und augen gebastelt jetzt kommen noch
die nahende und der kleine muck wird
gerne doch am rücken sowie schreiben
denn die diese torte ist für dich ich
habe viele tiere speed ist hast du ich
hab mir die tiere sie sind wunderschön
ich hoffe sie brauchen könnte
ich hab die tiere sie sind makellos und
laufend cat dort jeden tag auch mal
einen baum sitzen immer alles ist
perfekt
sie sind so neu ist jeder herzlich
du kommst aus die koppel mine verläuft
und die weiß setzen trauen werden unter
einem thema das problem ist es hat
einfach niemand geburtstag das heißt ich
werde diese torte mit ins büro nehmen
mir schneidet hier das stück weg das
macht mich an beute traurig die torte zu
essen
das ist für dich diese haben wir ganz
schön fest
ich habe noch nie etwas gemacht was so
gut von außen aussieht und so von ist
jetzt stellen wir uns wieder der
wichtigsten frage wie schmeckt originals
100 orte die hässlichste torte der welt
riesen fail gerettet durch mal war
hier finden sie auch guten appetit
[Musik]
hatte auf youtube wie man schon mal
freund reden weil eine torte gemacht hat
[Musik]
leute aber auch ganz einfach ich hoffe
dir gefällt die eine torte ansonsten
würde ich sagen abonniert diesem kanal
falls ihr noch mehr folgen tränen sehen
wollen und activia glocke hier gibt es
noch weitere videos heute live